this is Mardon not far from the borders
with Iraq and Syria the melting pot of
arrow Turkish Kurdish amuse ed cultures
and now it's providing 21st century
shelter to people escaping conflicts in
those neighboring countries the most
recent arrivals are their CDs escaping
the murderers advance of the group that
calls itself the Islamic state across
northern Iraq the azita's are an ancient
religion that takes influence from Islam
and Christianity but the yazidi faith is
widely misunderstood and the Islamic
state group are shown little tolerance
even for fellow Muslims deviate from the
ISS hardline interpretation of their
faith so they Aziz a frightened that the
is would show little torrents for their
religion
now turkey is already dealing with an
influx of refugees from Syria now turkey
is often complained that it doesn't get
enough help from the international
community to cover those enormous costs
future camps that it's building for the
Yazidis will be inside Kurdish
controlled Iraq there won't be any more
here in Turkey those camps in northern
Iraq shall be ready in mid-september to
house as many as 35 thousand more Yazidi
refugees many of the cds of course are
concerned that nowhere in iraq is safe
for them anymore one more download the
aj+ mobile app and join the conversation
available in your app store now